jeder der für so viele tote
verantwortlich ist sollte sich präsident
der usa bleiben
wir sind in einer situation wo über 1000
tote pro tag haben und es gibt über
70.000 neue infektionen pro tag der
präsident hatte nie ein plan und hat
auch jetzt keinen plan zur bekämpfung
der pandemie
ich sage ja nicht dass es schnell vorbei
geht sondern dass wir lernen damit
umzugehen wir können ja nicht alle im
keller verkriechen sowieso das macht
irgendwo hat er ja offensichtlich eine
menge geld verdient und fühlt sich wohl
wenn er sich in seinem keller verkriecht
aber das können ja nicht alle menschen
so machen und ich als präsident kann das
auch nicht so machen ich kann mich ja
auch nicht irgendwo im weißen haus
zurückziehen und mist da gemütlich
machen
ich habe bei jeder konferenz bei jeder
besprechung und ich habe mich auch mit
sehr vielen familien getroffen mit
angehörigen von militärs ich musste mich
doch persönlich mit leuten treffen das
wäre doch schrecklich gewesen wenn ich
das einfach alles abgesagt hätte
natürlich gibt es gefahren ich bin ja
selber infiziert worden und ich habe
dadurch sehr viel gelernt und jetzt habe
ich mich erholt 99,9 prozent der jungen
leute holen sich 90,9 prozent der
infizierten erholen sich wieder
wir müssen uns erholen wir müssen unser
land öffnen unsere schulen wieder öffnen
sonst haben wir keinen dann er steht auf
typen wie den chinesischen präsidenten
putin und den nordkoreanischen diktator
und er redet darüber das sind alles
freunde und er stößt damit unsere wahren
freunde und verbündeten vor den kopf 25
prozent der weltwirtschaft sind wir wir
müssen den rest der unserer freundin
unserer seite haben
sonst würden wir china nicht zwingen
können sich an die regeln zu halten
als ich mich mit barack obama getroffen
habe im weißen haus ganz am anfang da
haben wir wir sollten nicht nur 15
minuten miteinander reden dann hat das
nachher über eine stunde gedauert
ein großes thema und er sagte ganz klar
wenn es einen krieg mit nordkorea geben
sollte dann wird das ein atomkrieg sein
ich finde den nordkoreanischen
staatschef schwierig er mich
wahrscheinlich auch aber wir haben eine
beziehung zueinander auch wenn sie
schwierig egal wie gut man obamacare
verwaltet obamacare ist nicht gut
deswegen möchten wir das ganze beenden
die pflichtversicherung sollte dann auch
wegfallen wir werden einfach die ganze
krankenversicherung besser organisieren
und besser managen
aber ohne diese versicherungspflicht ist
das sowieso schon mal besser geworden
und ich möchte außerdem eine sehr viel
bessere versorgung für kranke menschen
und menschen mit vorerkrankungen werden
immer geschützt sein wir werden ein
großartiges ein tolles system anbieten
was ich machen werde ist obama der mit
einer öffentlichen option zu
verabschieden das wäre dann beiden care
nämlich wenn man für medicaid in frage
kommt dann werden sie automatisch
krankenversichert damit es wettbewerb
gibt für versicherungsunternehmen das
wird geschehen zweite werden
sicherstellen dass wir die prämien und
die medikamentenpreise herabsetzen in
dem wir auch da wettbewerb einführen der
im moment nicht besteht in dem wir
medica in die lage versetzen
medikamenten preis zu verhandeln
das doch abschaffen er wurde schon seit
jahren will er die sozialen
sicherungssysteme abschaffen schauen sie
sich seine bilanz an er wollte diese
systeme schon immer zerstört habe das
strafrecht reformieren lassen die
gefängnis reformieren lassen
ich habe die schwarzen hochschulen
unterstützt wofür man mir den vorwürfen
natürlich kann man immer irgendwas
behaupten aber mich macht das traurig
denn ich bin am wenigsten rassistisch
von allen hier ich kann die anderen gar
nicht sehen weil es hier so dunkel ist
aber ich bin der am
wenigsten rassistisch denkende hier im
raum er hier streut immer dies immer öl
ins feuer
er hatte gesagt lasst uns von diesen
lasst uns diese rassistischen
vergewaltiger diese mexikanischen
vergewaltiger los wäre er sagt wir haben
dürfen keine moslems mehr ins land hat
alles schlimmer gemacht
wir waren die letzten mal da hatte doch
den traut beuys gesagt haltet euch
zurück und haltet euch bereit
dieser mensch ist springt auf jeden
rassistischen zug dieses pariser
abkommen da bin ich für uns alle
ausgestiegen
denn das hätte uns millionen gekostet
und unsere unternehmen hätten gelitten
und ich werde nicht zehntausende
arbeitsplätze opfern und tausende von
unternehmen auch von nur aufgrund dieses
pariser abkommens denn das war total
unfair
china steigt erst 2020 30 1
und wir hätten sofort alles erfüllen
sollen
das hätte doch unsere wirtschaft
zerstört das heißt wir haben das dann
alleine großartig geleistet wir haben
jetzt die besten emissionen die
sauberste luft seit vielen vielen jahren
vielmehr jahre trump werden alle
regulierungen zerstören die wir zum
schutz des klimas eingeführt haben um
emissionen zu begrenzen
er wird uns in eine position wo wir
echte probleme kriegen wir werden dem
pariser abkommen wieder beitreten zu
zwingen den regeln zu fühlen wir sind
auf dem weg auf der straße des erfolges
er will ja für alle die steuern anheben
er will alles durch regulieren wenn er
ins amt kommt wird es eine depression
geben eine rezession geben wie sie sie
noch nie gesehen haben und das wird ein
sehr trauriger tag für das land ich
meine ein amerikanischer präsident ich
repräsentiere sie alle ob sich für
dagegen nicht gestimmt haben und ich
werde sicherstellen dass ihre interessen
vertreten sind wir werden ihnen hoffnung
geben gewährt uns für wissenschaften
statt fiktion entscheidung hoffnung
statt angst
wir werden enorme chancen realisieren um
die dinge zu verbessern wir können
wirtschaftswachstum erzielen können den
systemischen rassismus bekämpfen und
gleichzeitig sicherstellen dass unsere
wirtschaft in richtung sauberer energie
bewegt wird um damit millionen neue
arbeitsplätze zu schaffen und das ist
der fakt das werden wir tun
[Musik]